Christmas episode I love Christmas
episodes though this one really knows
how to test your patience man this is
holly jelly secrets part 1 we are
actually he was asking beforehand like
you want to do them together because we
have them back-to-back or do you want to
do you know what one after the other is
separate video for each I'm like let's
do a separate video so that I can see
what other people witness when they saw
it in everything and it's like man what
the hell can we talk about it's just
like it it is so tedious
um the boogers that was funny yeah
there's definitely some funny moments
but it's like - I hope it's building up
- so but okay you got this it's just an
it's a Christmas episode we finally have
a Christmas yeah but there's so little
Christmas in it so far - I mean are you
- us I cut the tail card I don't know
what it has to do with Christmas
um but me will find out that Christmas
it's I love Christmas elf oh come on you
know how much I love Christmas um that
was really excited - Christmas episode
it's like I see nothing Christmas
related yet but maybe it's all building
up maybe it's all building up well it's
all taking place in the ice King's realm
pretty much watching him exercise and
talk I mean another one video but it
actually takes place at Finn and Jake
that's ice and snow
well that case I can't be episodes
having Christmas episodes because
there's better all right so you got they
find these VHS 'iz which is funny enough
that they still have cameras ever cord
vhss they put a BMO's butt and they
watch it cuz the Ice King is saying
these are super secret evil videos and
they're just watching this video diary
that they're kind of like you know
webcam recordings you know - this is
what I'm doing now what I'm doing now
and they're like terrible be logs yeah
and I know I don't you hate those yeah
II imagine if you like just watch the
show and then talked about that B's
sewing I mean who's that full of
themselves
I don't know but so you got them
watching these uh
like usually I was actually these V logs
and they're just really boring and
really
oh that's the joke I know that's the
joke but it's like oh then the Ice King
finds out and at the end he's about to
freeze them and then it cuts it's like
that's the first like uncle I'm just
curious what its leading up to you know
it's like ala cos it's adventure time
and I'll they do good stuff obviously
it's like I'll I'll wait and see what
they're building up to but it's like
that's the oh you're big stop sticking
with it cuz it's like um like when the
fast-forwarding I'm waiting for like the
face of the devil or something to pop in
there it's just so you'd be like whoa
wait a minute that like I'm waiting for
the joke and wait for the payoff and
maybe maybe the payoff will just be all
the more funnier it with this much
build-up I don't know but man it's like
with this much build-up it's is gonna be
pretty damn funny um yeah cuz we're I
know the Ice King is pathetic I mean
this is nothing that new true and you
know and so much of it just depends on
what the payoff is that's one of reasons
this one's really hard to talk about um
what about all the Gunter's yeah well
weird how does that work again there's
two no there's there's a ivory penguin
is Gunter and every penguin is Gunter
Oh Gunter or Gunter depending on how I
say good sure cuz I'm kind of German no
it's both it's actually both yeah here
he goes back and forth I mean I mean
that's the thing all of them are named
that see there's numerous penguins I
always thought he was like just one
today called Gupta I didn't know like he
just there he had a time painting what
they just called him home that's kind of
what you're seeing now is that that the
penguin dance party he's going both home
good turn yeah good cause I was sort of
throwing me off I was like wait was it
oh okay
you're Gunther I guess we're all good
for at heart um so yeah I mean it's I
just don't know what to say it because
it's like it depends on how it pays off
because I'll put up with a lot if it has
a really good payoff um I always say the
one movie that totally kind of changed
the way I look at movies is called the
straight story have you ever seen that
no it's literally I won't give it away
but the whole film is actually designed
to be TD
long boring and annoying but then when
you get to the end it's like oh my god
this is brilliant
and it's it's like the only film I've
ever seen that has done that where the
ending has just changed everything it's
like oh it's like I get it um so I
always give it's very hard for me to
have me walk out on a movie you know
yeah our showers I'm like that you know
cuz it's like I try to give it up in the
doubt but there are a couple and I
wouldn't block out on this but I'm like
man I hope I hope it's another straight
story yeah I don't like that was
brilliant what a great payoff so I'm
just hoping for that so how about you
what are you getting at was first half I
mean you know what happens oh yeah
no um but actually when I first saw this
I was so excited because I'm a huge fan
of Christmas yeah love Christmas
specials and all that stuff in Christmas
episodes when I'm watching in him like
where's the Christmas until the Ice King
shows up with the gifts of the skunk and
a tree I didn't even think of that
you're right that's Christmassy I can't
that's about it I'm like where's
Christmas what's with this title cards
like this one we're looking in the cycle
um right now which is very funny second
Taiyo card Oh are both so Christmassy
and they look so good and they're well
drawn then they got wonderful color and
stuff just like this in the episode so
it may be this next one hopefully it's
in the in this next one but I do have a
mission if you will for the people who
watch this if you guys have the time and
effort because I'm too lazy to go
through the videos that they're watching
where they're fast-forwarding it slow it
down and see what he's actually saying
and tell me yeah I was I think there's
an actual dialogue no are there any and
but I'm not because a lot of times we'll
have stuff a little spic no no no but
he's saying stuff being character yeah
and that's what I'm curious exactly what
is he saying and then when they triple
time it because he's doing all the
exercises and there's one point in time
where he scrawled up in a ball on the
ground and I'm like wonder what he's
saying I'm sure somebody's done that
already
I'm too lazy to do it I will admit to
that but if you guys can that'd be kind
of cool and you have a family and a life
and stuff but for those who have no life
means I I didn't point anybody out I
said just for those I mean yes so the
people actually end up doing it you're
calling out I think by doing it they
called themselves out okay you are you
gonna be like you realize I have a life
and I'm a lawyer
and then you've earned the right to do
that you very strange bizarre cool
person that's always the argument I make
when like people get angry like a troll
or somebody attacker hero you stupid
like that and I'm always like just do
you think there's like some sort of rich
businessman with a martini and his
superhot wife just like oh darling you
know I was just I'm watching a web video
you know I saw this one I just said you
know what after I was done riding my fur
I and everything I just won't go on the
night just want to use the c-word over
and over you know I think you should do
that you're right god I love you so much
more fulfilling life we have just doing
this come on let's go I could totally
see someone doing that honestly doing
that I mean think about it hmm we just
did everything today in darling what are
we gonna do let's go talk to the peons
all the people doing that was just like
the massive trolling of the 1% percent
work they have to keep that money and
they have to do stuff and that money I
can't see them doing bad okay they have
to keep it with making fun of people
they're my people they're not using any
money doing this this is like a ten
minute thing each of us pick a website
we go on it we make fun of it for a few
minutes that cost us absolutely no money
takes up almost no time think about it
it is for the interesting thing about
rich people is they're so cheap so take
that one for now they're sticking it to
us yeah they got us by the nads
yeah there's no denying this but all
right so 1% get on slowing down that
video so we can figure out what the Ice
King said yes thank you